hey chair we are on well thank you
uh good morning everybody and welcome to
this latest meeting of the trafford
cobra 19 public engagement board
um attendances um thank you all for your
attendance i have apologies this morning
from councillor evans
and i think i'm welcoming nick young
from gmp standing in for caroline
hemingway are there any further
apologies we know of at all please
fabiola uh no other apologies received
i'm aware cancer accordingly is trying
to join the meeting
there are some technical issues but
we'll keep watching
to make sure easy thank you thank you
for that um
item two on the agenda declarations of
interest are there any declarations of
interest in any of the agenda items this
morning please thank you
silence uh the minutes of the last
meeting can i please take these as read
they have been
circulated
thank you item for the update on the
current kobe 90 situation in trafford
eleanor uh i believe you're going to
give us something around about data
accuracy as well this morning is that
correct
yes okay so i think the
general good news is that um i think
when we met two weeks ago i was getting
worried that our
rates were stalling that they were
declining but that decline had finished
stopped we are now seeing um rates come
down further which
is really very very good news but
a word of caution covid is still very
real
and the rates are still higher than they
were for example in september
but the fact that they're coming down
and they're coming down well is is
really good news
we are expecting to see rates go up a
little bit over the next couple of weeks
um probably starting we'd expect to see
a bit of a bump in rates
um with schools going back that's not
because schools aren't safe
it but when as soon as you open up
another workplace another setting like
that you will see more spread just
because of
more social mixing but the schools have
introduced obviously have been engaged
with the
testing program and we've got people on
the call who can talk more about that
programme
and that we've got had really good
engagement with our schools with our
parents and with our young people
in that program but we would expect as i
say we would expect to see a slight rise
in rates because more people are going
out and about and seeing each other
so the general message is if you can
still work from home you should work
from home don't take your children going
back to school as being a sign that
you can go back to work we would
absolutely say now is
having having um allowed one part of the
society to open up a little bit more
the rest of us need to really make sure
that we do everything we can to keep the
rates down
because i think we're all the the dates
within the national road map
are very much dependent on us keeping
those rates down
so so that's just a word of caution and
a reminder to everybody that
now is the time to be particularly
careful
the other good news is our vaccination
rates are going really well we have
um over 90 i think overall 93
of our population um in the top four
priority groups
have been vaccinated but we've seen
quite a bit of
variation by um particularly by
geography within that
and our population in the north of the
trafford in north trafford so
we're only on about 83 i mean that is
still very very good uptake
um and but it is that population
we're particularly concerned about
making sure that we get that good spread
of vaccination across all groups in our
society
because we know that some people
particularly where there's particularly
vulnerability to
covid we don't want to have large groups
unvaccinated and risking the spread of
disease
within those populations particularly
groups who are more likely to have to do
face-to-face work or in overcrowded
accommodation where the risks become
become higher so um i had a question
about whether the data was
accurate and uh for the north of the
borough
and we think it is accurate we think
that it's it's likely that that
we do have that difference um between
that 10 difference between the north
and the rest of the borough um the
reason that we think it's accurate
is that we have that same data set that
the we've got different sources of data
so both the ccg data
and our and the council data are telling
the same story
um also we do see at this a difference
in uptake and vaccination
um in the more deprived areas normally
so that is so if you like the pattern
that we're seeing is a pattern we'd
expect to see but it's not not a pattern
that we
feel happy with this is something that
we are working really hard to address
and what we're doing with um certainly
nigel will be able to talk about the
work we're doing with our comms and
engagement team
uh and our copa community champions on
addressing concerns about vaccination
and making sure that people are
confident in the vaccination
and and are happy that the vaccine is
safe um what we're seeing i think is
um not so much that people are refusing
it but people are wanting a bit more
time to think about it
and that's absolutely fair enough it's
you know it is a pro you know a
vaccination something you should think
about seriously
but it's just to reassure people that it
is safe and we're working with local
communities um to listen to their
concerns and to try and make sure that
we address
those
you elena um i've got council
accordingly uh wishing to ask a question
council accordingly
um and thanks to chair it's just to
clarify this um
data for the north it's not refusals
that i'm particularly
concerned about in terms of the data
that looks about right and it's
it's a higher level of refusal in the
north and i think we
we need to work on that but the figures
that i'm getting in the um
uh covet dashboard i mean the last
last week it was showing 74
for the um first four cohorts
i've looked on the um nhs data
there's nothing approaching that i think
tower hamlets has the
one of the lowest levels and it's just
about on that
level so it just seems so significantly
different
that 74 take up in
in the first four cohorts it's only
three quarters
um and i know that uh in the north
they're inviting
well down the um the cohorts so
i i'm just dubious about that data
showing
74 we're not it's not as
i realize there may be some reluctance
to go
but we're not sensing it doesn't seem to
be
feeling that way on the ground there's
people that are refusing there will be
people prevaricating but
74 that's three quarters that just seems
hugely significant so um i think uh
and i think if tomorrow been issues on
the call i think we've we may have
um access to slightly more up-to-date
data and of course there were a lot of
vaccinations done over the weekend
so i think we're now on 83 in the north
i think one of the things we need to be
a bit cautious about is comparing
a small area within our borough to um
a whole borough somewhere else because
so yeah
so yes so so i suspect if tower hamlets
have an overall rate of say 75 percent
they will have some areas in that on 90
in some areas in that on 60 percent
um and what we've got in in trafford is
we don't have
very fortunately we don't have that
range we we've done
you know the people are are accepting us
in our
um in in the north we are getting that
good uptake
um compared to many other vaccines um so
so it is a very very good news story and
i would really encourage everybody in
across the whole of the borough to make
sure that they do accept the vaccine
when it's when it's offered to them um
we do have a higher rate of decline in
the north and that is
you know substantially higher
particularly in some of our older
populations
what we're trying to do is obviously
make sure that people have an
opportunity to revisit any decision
so um but also we don't want to um you
know
harangue people and um harass them into
into having the vaccination so we're
trying to make sure that people
continue to know that it's available to
them even if they think it's not for
them
at this moment um and and they we know
as well
particularly when you get to quite small
numbers we're talking in some cases
of the difference between um reaching
the target
and not reaching the same 90 target and
not
is is maybe 10 people so we're working
with
voice of bme and other groups um within
particularly in the north trafford but
actually across the board trying to make
sure that everywhere
we get that if where people are if we
see any patterns where people are
it looks like people are being hesitant
by the vaccination
making sure that we get in there and
have those conversations
we've been doing webinars with people
but the other thing is obviously it's
that
um being able to ask a question face to
face
is really important for people so we're
just making sure that we're giving every
opportunity
both in the materials that we produce
the conversations we have
and um q a sessions and so on for
particular targeted particular groups
so that people have a real opportunity
the other thing that we're doing is
obviously i think
particularly as we move down into
younger age groups
where people perhaps feel that the
vaccination won't make as much
difference to them because they don't
feel as
as at risk from covid we are really
trying to make sure that we don't have
any systematic inequality in the uptake
of that vaccination
so we've been really trying to make sure
that we get those messages across about
the vaccine being safe for everyone
and actually that kovid does
you know what it is such an odd disease
because we have so many people who have
no symptoms whatsoever
and then we have other people who are
perfectly fit and healthy and
can be really really seriously ill even
in their 30s and 40s
um you know where where people have
become very very ill or have
and and ended up in hospital with it or
have ended up with long covered
and really you know quite debilitating
symptoms going on for a very very long
time of exhaustion
aches fatigue arrange a range of
different symptoms
so we are really trying to make sure
that people don't
don't underestimate the risk that kovid
presents
to anyone at any age and the other good
news i think about the vaccination the
other good reason for everybody to
accept
vaccination when it's offered is that it
does seem to be present helping prevent
transmission as well as stopping you
being seriously ill
so even if you are in your 20s or 30s
we know our rates of infection are
highest in people in their 20s
so once we get we really do want to make
sure we get very very good uptake and
vaccination
for that group because although they may
not be seriously ill themselves
the risk of long covert as i say remains
very real
um but also that um they obviously are
if they don't if they're not vaccinated
they may well give it to somebody else
so it's it's trying to keep those
messages um
but i think um i think our data is is
accurate
because we're now when we work with the
ccg as well
we're able now to try and get it we'll
be able to get it right down to those
individual areas and we do know
which particular streets and so on in
traffic have lower rates
so one of our plans is going you know
we'll be doing if
if we've got more um vaccination
sessions running this weekend
but we will be intending to go and do
probably door knocking as well
just so that people can have an
opportunity to talk about vaccination
and anything else actually that they're
worried about
with covid whether it's about testing
whether it's about self-isolation
whatever whatever it is so we can learn
from people and make sure that we
provide
the services in the way that people want
them
thank you elena that's a very very
reassuring resume that we've had from
you is there any further questions at
all for
uh alan hurtle
i don't see any at all uh before we move
on can i just say about the rates
falling
i do recall um in about may june last
year when our rates
reached the 50 in the 50s for the first
time and how
very very concerned and panicky we all
were about it
this time it's like the rates coming
down is much more of a relief but as you
say elena
there is absolutely no room for
complacency
it's still with us and people still got
to take the precautions and
i was pleased to see yesterday that both
chris whittie and patrick valance were
both advocating there's no quick
road out of this lockdown and i think
we've got to remember that it's about
managing
our public's expectations about this as
well
uh thank you can i move on then to item
five and start with much testing
in traffic invite donna to speak to us
about that thank you donna
thank you chair um so just a quick
update really in terms of the
um asymptomatic testing programs that
we've been running in trafford
as you know the military left us last a
couple of weeks ago now
so the site is operational with traffic
council staff
and is still proving to be very popular
and there are now discussions about
different ways in which our local
residents can
access lateral flow testing um and
um in the main this the the guidance is
really for
staff who are sorry for residents who
are either
in a family where a child is going to
school or in a family where there is
teacher
and those currently can be collected
from
the sites at partington or the sites at
um
trafford house we are chair looking to
see now about whether we can use our
libraries
um and our community hubs and three of
our community hubs have
kindly agreed to to do that and also
four of our libraries will be doing that
so we've put in an expression of
interest
to greater manchester to enable us to
have further
supplies of the kit so then we can make
it available to local residents
i think in terms of the future um
there's this likely that lateral flow
test will be
clearly part of that road to recovery
and so the
the emphasis for us in trafford will be
to make sure that they're available
um as easily um to residents and can be
accessed that way
so that's just really the quick update
i'll perhaps hand over to
um kate in terms of talking about
testing in schools
if that's all right with you chair
yes please please do so kate
thank you and yeah we um have been
working with our school since the
announcement that testing in schools was
going to be ruled out
rolled out and and all schools have
embraced this
within trafford um the primary school
testing model at the moment
is for staff only so all staff
have been invited to test at home and
that's
two twice a week three to four days
apart
secondary staff were being tested on
site within secondary schools
but that model has now shifted to a home
testing model as well
um and the schools are all the secondary
schools are all busy working
through the task of testing their pupils
now that the pupils are returning
and there has been able to be a
staggered start this week for secondary
pupils returning to enable that testing
to take place
that testing consists again of three
tests on site
three to five days apart and then once
the pupils have had the opportunity to
practice testing on the site
and become more skilled in the technique
that will move to a home testing offer
for those that consent
and it's been absolutely embraced by all
of our schools but as donna said we're
also working with the schools to promote
the testing for family bubbles
associated with school children and
school staff
thank you kate are there any questions
at all for donner or cates
i don't see any at all um to come and
move on to
mass vaccination can i invite martin
britshard
to address us thank you martin thank you
jeff
and uh as you said when you were
discussing um eleanor's update
it's really important isn't it that the
vaccination program continues to go well
because the first of the government's
four tests
from moving through the stages of
restrictions from lockdown is that the
vaccination program
continues to be a success and i i think
both nationally and in greater
manchester in trafford it remains so
so i'm going to go through where we are
in terms of supply where we are in terms
of the
vaccine hesitancy where we are in terms
of
moving through the cohorts and then i'm
going to
end before i open up for all your
questions
in terms of what the data is starting to
show in terms of the impact
of the vaccination program so
supply-wise as you would have seen
no doubt from national and local media
over the last 10 days or so
you've seen a slowing down nationally of
the vaccination programme and that
reflects uh
a period where we've had um slightly
less supply than we've got
um used to but um from next week
from the 15th of march what we're seeing
is i think due to a ramping up of the
manufacturing process
we're going to see larger and larger
numbers of vaccines coming through
and this is particularly important
because as of last week
we really started to get into the second
dose of vaccinations because we're
10 11 12 weeks away from the start of
the process
so now we're recalling people back for
their second dose
but next week we'll be getting 7 000
first dose
vaccines into trafford which is quite a
considerable number and on top of that
sufficient vaccines for second doses for
those people whose time is to have a
second dose
it's too early to say what the data is
in terms
of the take-up in terms of the second
dose
and i think it's it's really important
isn't it that we get the message across
between us that whilst the first dose
seems to give very very good um coverage
very very good
um support for people not to become
either infected or seriously ill
it's really important that people take
up that opportunity for the second dose
but it's too early to see
in the data what the take-up is and
whether there's any variation between
age groups or localities or members our
community or any of those things but
we'll keep an eye on that
i think next time we have this this
meeting we should have some good data
about what the take of the second
dose is and we're working really closely
with
with nhs england to make sure that the
supply of vaccines into traffic into our
various
uh vaccinators matches what they need
going forward in terms of the progress
that they've made on the cohorts
so i'm really pleased to say that the
supply of vaccine next week is really
good
and i'm really pleased to say that the
uh the matching of where we need to get
that vaccine to in terms of make further
progress is really good as well
in terms of vaccine hesitancy um eleanor
i think you've
you've covered a lot of this i'd just
like to say that i think the data is
is absolutely sound um we look at
gp records and gp records are
um you know one of the best data sets
that that we have so
i don't think there's a great issue
about data quality in this
i think what we're seeing is absolutely
reflection of greater hesitancy
in the north of alberta than in other
parts of the borough
and i think through the work that we've
done it's absolutely clear that there is
no
single solution to this there is no
magic bullet that if you do this
um you know that vaccine hesitantly goes
away in communities
it is absolutely i think um a whole
series of measures
measures done in conjunction with each
other and and everybody
and every partner playing their part in
this and what we've seen is a
magnificent effort from
a whole range of community leaders and
organizations in this
um eleanor may want to comment but the
one of the issues in this is it's quite
hard i think eleanor isn't it to work
out causality
so what what thing do you do that has
the greatest impact in terms of
vaccine hesitancy and i'm sure in the in
the months ahead we'll get better
understanding of that both nationally
and in traffic so we can concentrate our
efforts on those things that
that work so in terms of the cohorts um
still a focus in in gps on cohorts one
to six
um but through the mass vaccination
program um through the mass vaccination
centre in the community pharmacy
we're now well into cohorts seven and
eight and cohort seven is those people
aged 60 to 64.
and cohort eight is those people aged 56
to 60 so we're absolutely moving through
these cohorts at some
real pace now and that uh target that's
been said nationally of getting through
to a first dose of everybody in cohorts
one to nine by the
by the the middle to end of april i'm
pretty confident we'll be getting there
at this rate
i think we'll probably um no i'm not
going to say it
i'm pretty confident we'll we'll get
there
um and then finally and um i mean this
is the most heartening bit of
of the whole program we have over the
last year um
developed some models with the
university of manchester and with
various organizations across greater
manchester
that has allowed us to make some pretty
clear predictions which is
if we have this level of infection in
our community
then we are going to have this number of
people admittedly admitted into hospital
we are going to have this number of
people admitted into critical care
we are going to have this number of
people who are likely to die
we are going to have this number of
people who are going to be discharged in
need of
further support for rehabilitation and
that model has been
um it's been very accurate and it's
allowed us to plans allowed us to take
measures
and what we're seeing now in that model
for the first time
is um is our divergence between those
numbers
and that's incredibly positive and
that's down to the effect of the
vaccination program
and what that says to me is the
vaccination program is working
we can see the impact of it and that's
just absolutely
brilliant some of that data is from
international studies particularly
israel because they're first advanced
but we're starting to see
unpublished studies in the united
kingdom that reflect that stuff
and that is just absolutely fantastic
because it shows that all the effort
that everybody's put into this is having
an impact
and it also shows what we all want to
see isn't it which is
the vaccination program is working and
that's some of the other steps that will
enable us to move away from restrictions
and hopefully hopefully
move towards some greater normality so
i'm just going to leave you some with
some figures and i will
do my best to answer your questions in
terms of care homes cohort one
96 percent of people in trafford about
their first vaccine
over 80s 97 over 75
96 over 70s and people clinically
extremely vulnerable so this includes
a large number of younger people as well
back to eleanor's comments about
younger people and complacency their 89
those over 65 90 are those
um those in cohort 6 16 to 64 which
includes carers and people with
long-term conditions 64
and then we get to cohort seven which is
60 to 64.
it's 39 and cohort eight she's 56 to 60s
um already 22 of people in that cohort
have received
a first dose of that vaccination now
that heights variation and we know that
heights variation but what that says to
me is
this is a very successful vaccination
program and we're
absolutely working through the cohorts a
pace that if you'd have said we'd have
been here at this point in january
i would have been both very surprised
and very pleased
so thank you chair i hope that's a
useful update for you
thank you martin i have a question from
council accordingly
class accordingly
because accordingly
[Music]
sorry i touched the uh unmute but i must
have done a double click
um yeah it's more of a comment really on
um
uh the the north if we if we don't have
a magic bullet
um which we don't to increase the uh
take up and if it is at eight to two
percent that's still
there's still probably a thousand people
in the first four
cohorts i mean it was um it was eleven
hundred on
seventy four percent so my master it
might be just below
a thousand people but it's quite a
significant amount of
over 70s who have not had the um
the vaccine and a sort of dragging their
feet a little bit
what we do know that i mean
we the the the the the centers that we
have
none of them are on the bus none of them
are on bus routes
the limelight isn't on bus route seymour
grove isn't on a primary
bus route uh delamere center's not on
any bus route
um in some ways there are a lot of
factors that might just push
somebody who's already reluctant may
drag their feet a little bit more
when they see that it is difficult to
get to
and there's no reason why over 70s
should not be using buses really and um
i'm wondering if we can start thinking
about transport solutions
and other things that might apply
they're not going to be a magic bullet
they're just going to be
incremental little incentives to get
people to these centers i think
that we have to do we have to
acknowledge that if somebody's
scared of it then the last thing you
need to do is make it difficult for them
to get to the center
and at the moment it is difficult in the
north
um the alternatives the nhs provide
is um wally range cricket club which
isn't again because the radial nature of
public transport is not
easy to get to from trafford it's not on
a route to town
uh or the etihad so you've got the
metrolink but that's a hell of a trek
as i know as a city fan um so yeah
i think there's a lot i think we need to
be drilling down and looking at
little things little measures that
not just the persuasion on the doorstep
but little measures that make it easier
to get to the centers
that's my view anyway
i'm i mean i'm i completely agree with
you um mike we are
we are making sure that we've so the
we've been looking at
exactly which um areas within old
trafford
have lower uptake and we do know that
actually quite a lot of it is right in
walking distance of limelight
so one of the things has been about
making sure that we've not only
um as the fact it's been difficult
because of the vaccine supplies
but making sure that the um we're able
to run some clinics
at limelight and there's there was a
clinic there last week last weekend and
there's another one i think next week
nigel can confirm the dates um so it
absolutely is because i think
um when people the people i think in um
with the covert vaccination there's been
a lot of people who really really want
to be vaccinated
and including in old trafford and a lot
of people have been
really prepared to travel and make ev
you know go quite a way out of their way
to get
vaccination and then there's another
group of people who are much more
cautious about it and that the group who
are cautious
need all sorts of things to happen to
make it easier for them
but we also know of course that our
population in old trafford
are much less likely to have access to
private cars
than many other people in trafford and
particularly at the moment
especially if you're if you're over 70
if you've been being really careful
you've not been going out
the last thing you're going to want to
do is get on a bus for vaccination and
we've been offering volunteers with cars
but again
i can completely understand why at this
point people wouldn't want to be getting
in a car with somebody they don't know
who's not a household member
so what we've been doing is um and
making sure that we've been able to run
some clinics in the
in the north and we're now trying to
make sure that we get really good notice
of when those clinics can be run
as the vaccine supply gets better it'll
be much easier for us to plan
previously because of the way the
vaccine supply was coming in
we quite often wouldn't know at the
beginning of one week whether we were
going to be able to have the vaccine
in that area in order to be able to run
the clinic
we're able to do a lot more planning now
and so the two pieces of work we're
doing is one making sure that
through the work that nigel's doing in
the work of all his teams as well as the
work obviously that the gps are doing
routinely
is making sure that we really create a
demand for vaccination that we may
that we get people into a place where
they want to be vaccinated
and the second thing we're doing is
making sure that we we can publicize
which clinics are there in walking
distance that will be easy for people to
get to
easy to book onto and making sure that
we can we can do that
for people so it is absolutely is
several approaches
that we're needing to take with this
because it's not one message
working for everyone and it's not um one
solution for everyone
having a local clinic isn't enough on
its own if you don't create the demand
for the vaccine
you can have as many local clinics as
you like and we and we still won't use
that and we learned that the hard way i
think um
certainly in my trying to increase mmr
when i worked in a different borough
to try and we thought oh well brilliant
all these people who aren't vaccinated
will take the vaccines to the schools
we'll run a clinic at school
so all the parents when they're dropping
off children can have their little ones
vaccinated
didn't work at all we took we got about
one vaccine
some vaccinated so it really is about
working with people to understand what
they want
and making sure that the vaccination is
there in an accessible place when they
want it but the main thing is
helping people understand why why we
think it's such a good idea
why we are so passionately behind
vaccination
this this you know why why the nhs has
been so
absolutely delighted to be the place
that the staff in the nhs have been
absolutely cueing up to be those people
to be vaccinated first if we didn't
think it was safe if we didn't think it
would work
we would not be queuing up to have this
vaccine so
we really want to make sure that other
people understand our passion for this
vaccine
and from public health perspective
actually i would say
my passion for vaccination more
generally um
so so that it it we really are we unders
it's a really really complicated issue
and there are lots of very um names on
it today very honest understandable
reasons why people are hesitant
and why people need to have their
confidence built in the vaccination but
i think
now that we can see so many people in
this country have been vaccinated
with with no ill effect and we're seeing
hospitalizations and deaths coming down
it really is time to go you know it's
safe please
please have that vaccine thanks
i've got three lined up for questions
now can i start with counselor her dad
please
um thank you um it's the first time i've
come to this meeting and i apologized
chair i was late so i've just come in to
the end of this so
if my question has missed something and
again i apologize because this is a
really important
um venue and public engagement
committee um which i have wanted to come
to before
so um i was think i was listening to you
saying
martin that it's 8 82
up uptake of the vaccine so there's
you know which is good and um you're
talking about vaccine hesitancy and my
question was really
um agreeing with eleanor you know it's
it's not just
you know somebody who's who's done a lot
in vaccines herself
that's got experience as a healthcare
worker
it's not just where they're located it's
about
with vaccine hesitancy it's the
education that surrounds it
and again i apologize if you have done
something about this but i just wondered
what the education packages
is around it you know um and
if you could give me some explanation
about that and whether you think
you have done enough or you need to do
more or
what's happening thank you so um i think
probably if i hand over to nigel and i
think
i think what i would say is we've done
absolutely we've done a lot
we need to do loads more it's not
something we can stop
it and i think the point martin was
making about the second vaccine
is really important because the first
vaccine does give really good protection
but you do need that second vaccine to
to promote to
make sure that that protection lasts and
get those extra few percentage points on
it so
and and the length of um the length of
the effect
we don't know whether people will have a
different reaction to the second dose
than the first dose
a reaction to a vaccination is a good
thing because it shows the vaccines
working
but it is again making sure that people
are really well prepared for
any side effects because it's
you know we cut if you had a vaccine
with no side effects it could be because
the vaccine isn't working
so it's really important you should be
you know the message we need to be
giving is if you get side effects
you know that's that's not a bad thing
at all
if they seem really severe or if they go
on for a longer time than you would
expect more than 24 hours
there might be something else you might
have another you know it could be
something completely different so do
if they don't seem if you feel ill then
you think you should be
if you're worried about it if they go on
for more than 24 hours absolutely go and
see your doctor call 111
because it might not be anything to do
with the vaccine i think that's the
point eleanor i'm sure you are doing a
lot it's just
how are we doing it you know the message
i mean now
i was just shocked reading this week
that there's been 2.6 million deaths
globally and like you say people
understanding
the vaccination itself it's not a live
vaccine
it's a it's a kind of um if you like a
messenger
to our internal you know body to code
that we get some defense to it because
it's an rna
and type vaccine but i just wondered you
know drilling down into what kind of
education and how we're doing the
education are we doing it
you know through leaflets are we going
out locally to communities what are we
doing so we're doing absolutely
everything so
obviously there's the leaflets and the
information that comes straight from the
gps
then we're doing webinars for different
groups so we've been doing webinars for
staff groups for different population
groups
um helen and beenish who are in the
public health team we're on a webinar
for the um altering them and hail muslim
association
on friday evening but what i'm going to
do is i'm going to hand over to nigel so
we've been doing webinars we've been
doing leaflets and we've been doing
face-to-face
and we're just going to have to keep on
keeping on with it
but as we get more and more data about
where we get the lower uptake
we can really drill down and what we're
really focusing is not on what we're
doing
what we're trying to do is make sure we
give the messages to other people so
other people can deliver
the messages in using more effective
language than i can use because the
things that i can say might well
work well for other women in their 50s
but probably are absolutely not going to
cut it for you know other some other
populations um
questions in the apps you know
so it's it's i suppose we would say
mainly we're talking about engagement
and understanding from
other people what what their concerns
are rather than
education per se but can i hand over to
nigel and he can give a summary of some
of the things we've done
and i'm sure um and then but this is all
on top of the work that the ccg are
doing as well
which is much you know which is really
promoting it and working with individual
patients as well
through the ccg role so hand over to
nigel on that
thank you thank you thanks all right
would it be helpful for me to go through
my jet because i'm going to cover a lot
of this work through my general update
so i don't if you want to go
uncover it all please thank you okay
that's great thanks cancer freeman
so yeah so um in terms of the work of
the uh community engagement team
it is it's very much focused as you
expect on the vaccine hesitancy work so
there's a whole range of work that we're
doing um it's a big priority for the
team
and we coordinate this work through
weekly meetings that we have
we have a meeting there's a vaccine
operational group that's led by the ccg
so we attend that and we have internal
meetings as well every week to kind of
review the actions
that that we're doing so um one of the
key things we're doing
is to obviously promote and support
the local clinics such as the
particularly the new old trafford
vaccination clinics at sema grove and
limelight
to um to help increase the vaccine
uptake in these areas because these are
the areas where
we are seeing the lowest uptake so we're
going to continue to promote those
clinics as well as gathering
intelligence and understanding at the
same time around any lack of uptake
so linked to this we have also um
been supporting the community
volunteering program so there's a number
of volunteers as you all know that all
support the staff that are working at
the vaccination clinics so
we do this together with colleagues at
thrive and the ccg
and in particular those ones at
limelight at sema grove and the one in
partington
they're ones where we are helping to get
volunteers and
in terms of the um the clinic last
thursday
at limelight what was really heartening
we had um
one of our neighborhood leads working
there helping to coordinate the
volunteers and the sense that he was
getting was that the vast majority of
the people that were coming to that
clinic
were people that were were walking there
there was very few people driving there
so it
so that would lead you to think that
most of people are from that local
community
very short walking distance
um to help with this uh work as well
we're also
looking to recruit a volunteer
coordinator
so this will help to enhance the
volunteer offer further that we can help
in coordinating this work at the clinics
as we mentioned last two weeks ago the
last pebb
we are working with voice of bme so
they're going to be supporting
particularly the north primary care
practices by contacting
patients who who haven't taken up the
vaccine
to um via phone calls to
understand their concerns and offering
sort of practical
support to them and
the other thing that we're looking to do
is um
to develop a specific kind of
communication engagement campaign
for the north of trafford uh later on
this month
to probably over a two week period to
help alleviate concerns that people may
have and also promote the vaccine uptake
so this will build on the the one-to-one
phone calls that voice of bma
have been doing but will involve um
so we haven't done any of this so far
but what we're wanting to do in this
period of time over this two week period
is to
door knocking to speak to individual
households
in areas where we're seeing particularly
low uptake
so it's going to be very much data-led
and during those conversations we're
wanting to
very much promote those local clinics
making sure people are
aware that they're there on which days
listen to concerns issues that people
have and to provide reassurance where we
can and any further information
and we're also going to be developing
some leaflets and materials in different
languages as well that we can
hand out to people to again to promote
the clinics and the various support
that's available and to link in with
that kind of two week bit of work we're
also looking at potentially some
um advertising as well whether that's
outboard digital advertising or possibly
the use of an i-band signage
uh vehicle at key locations
so that just depends on whether we're
going to be doing a wider comms piece
or some targeted activity very much
depending on what the
what the data is showing and all backed
up with some
social media so another thing that we've
been doing for a number of weeks now is
providing uh messaging in through the
friday prayers
at the local mosques in the north so
we're doing this every week now
so not only is that messaging going out
through the friday prayers but also the
imams are able to share
through the whatsapp groups that they
have where they have between five
hundred to a thousand
uh people on those whatsapp groups
we have also as uh eleanor has said
we've been doing a number of um
webinars and q a sessions led by
sort of our public health colleagues
aimed at different groups so
recently we did q a sessions and
webinars with
the caribbean african health network
khan and voice of bme
last week the we had public health two
of our public health specialists
supporting
a q and a session that was run by the
altering the hail muslim association
that's a a hma
this week not forgetting all our council
staff we're there's a series of webinars
and q a sessions that we're running with
staff and key groups so
again to engage with our staff
understand concerns so there's two
webinars that are aimed at children's
services two at care home staff
and two aimed at just a wider staff
group
and the aim is for those sessions to be
recorded
and shared as well further
so just give a couple of examples of
some of the kinds of things we're doing
in in other areas in sale
um we've developed some targeted
community messaging at the life center
in partnership with
center and with salehob and we're making
use of the digital screens they've got
there
and other signage in the waiting room so
that people
while they're having the you know
waiting to have the vaccine and during
the 15-minute wait afterwards
there's messaging around um what to do
after the vaccination the importance of
the second dose
about the road map after you know for
ending lockdown and also
other stuff such as the dubai to support
that the community hub offer
i've also been linking in with
colleagues at imparting to
gmp and environmental health around
reinforcing the covert guidelines
getting
enhanced floor stenciling and engagement
with local businesses so just some of
the other activities that's been going
on
in other areas in terms of the team
itself
for those of you that haven't attended
the peb
before we have um four neighborhood
leads uh so north south central and west
who are um focused on
engagement activity in those areas
and uh building up community contacts um
in in those four neighborhood areas and
to give us a bit more capacity we've
also we're also recruiting
for neighborhood engagement offices as
well who were
going to be on uh temporary contracts
for six months
so we've recruited to those posts we're
waiting for start dates
but um they should hopefully be imposed
in the next few weeks so that will
really help
help us again with that capacity on the
ground
so the other thing we've talked about is
our community champions work
so um this is something that we're
seeing it's gonna happen like three
phases to it but the first phase
it's going to be around launching um a
web page which we finalize that now
we're looking to launch this within the
next two weeks
so this is around hopefully building up
a wide network of people
within the the all the trafford
communities who can
be champions and share messaging
throughout
their connections whether it's five
people whether it's ten people
or much more than that and we'll be
giving them
regular updates and the latest
information about covid which they can
then
share but we'll also give them support
through regular kind of weekly sessions
where they can check in
with the community engagement team and
check in with the public
health teams as well so that's the kind
of range of stuff we've been working on
and also not forgetting support for
businesses as well
so we have um we did a business webinar
which was held last month
so snippets from that webinar have now
been shared with
other businesses through various
business contacts that we have for
example through the economic growth
teams business networks
and we're potentially looking at doing
further webinars with businesses and
working with colleagues out of the gm
authorities so through all this work we
work very closely with the
the com with le cadec and the the coms
team
so for example they support us we're
getting
messaging out to promote the vaccine
clinics through through
social media promoting the webinars that
we have
they've been also getting out various
messaging for example around picking up
on the return to school
and providing reassurance to parents
around the national back to school
and uh also promoting support available
to businesses
and uh for example the high street
reopening campaign so that just gives
you a flavor of the kind of work
yeah yeah yeah we've been doing i hope
that that's helpful
it's it's per thank you nigel i mean i
can see you know you're really
um getting on top of it and i just you
know i was
very interested in obviously it's a
major um
concern to us all and that everybody
gets the vaccine
i just wanted with those message
messaging and the webinars and
you've obviously got an education
package that you can
put out so will you i presume you have
got sort of a
you know streamlined education package
that you can
send to people to support them with how
they
give the message and how they educate
people and if they're doing that through
whatsapp
groups is that something that they can
you know disseminate those groups
[Music]
so what we've tended to focus is having
quite short simple messaging that we're
expecting we're hoping that community
groups
and um community leaders that we have
can then
share through their networks rather than
a package that we're sending out to them
uh we have got various slides and our
own pack that our
public health colleagues uh go through
with with the webinars that we've been
running
but at the moment we haven't got a big
pack of information that we're
sending out in that sense
thank you thank you uh nigel i think
that's very very comprehensive what
you've given to us
i do have um uh councillor acton waiting
to ask a question cancer acting
yeah thanks chair um yeah i mean
first thing i want to say is that um you
know
thank all all the you know the workers
that have
got these jabbed into people's arms and
they have
you know worked tirelessly and
and i think generally the backseat
vaccinations have gone really really
well in trafford
um i i i do
just ask one one question really um
and it goes back to what mike has talked
about and
um because obviously we you know
myself and mike and akilah and and
other counsellors are concerned
in their areas as ever all counselors
are in
in their areas and i think um mike has
raised you know some some really valid
points and we you know we did touch on
this
uh that last time but what i would like
to
to to know is because obviously there
are other pockets
of um you know deprived areas
uh within the borough um you know
like like partington and broadhead and
other areas
um and and sale
and um
do you do a comparisons in those
deprived areas and pockets of areas
uh with the north of the borough
or is that difficult to you know
to sort of drive down uh that kind of
information
um so it's just because i think
we might learn a lot if if we can
compare
say say partington you know
um as air uptake uh been
like it has in the north of the borough
so it is things like that really that
would be interesting because then you
could actually
you know if say parting to nor you know
sail west and and and so on um
you know the uptake was poor there as
well or not as high as
the other areas um where where it goes
well so
um it's a convoluted question but i just
wonder if there is any information
around that there is information on that
and that is absolutely what we're doing
so we're we're
a lot of this information isn't in the
public domain because you can get down
to quite small numbers
and obviously we don't want to do
anything that's personally identifiable
but the data we have has postcodes on it
has
um has age sex ethnicity so we can cut
the data in all sorts of different ways
so we can really see whether where the
where the issues are um and make sure
that we can then target our efforts
and certainly we're not seeing the same
overall and this happens with every
vaccination program
we do tend to see lower rates by
deprivation so
in more deprived areas have lower uptake
of vaccination
than less deprived areas and that's
that's across the board
but there's an awful lot you can do in
those areas to increase the vaccination
rates so it's it's about understanding
where you're like you know i think this
this vaccination program is
if you like mirroring what we tend to
see normally
actually we've had better uptake in some
in areas such as partington
than we would often get so we've we've
been able to see some really good
good uptake in some areas and that re
again it reassures us that there is
things you can do
but i would i would continue to i mean i
used to work in north manchester which
is
a very very deprived area much more than
any of
any of trafford and we went from being
with flu vaccinations some years ago we
went
from having the lowest rates in greater
manchester to um i think highest and
second highest
so it's absolutely about how you
organize and how you engage with people
rather than
it being something that we just sit and
go well that's what it is that's not
what it is
um we will we will improve can i just
ask them
could you know put partington is his
sort of clusters deprived area and
it's doing well are the lessons that we
learn
from that area that we can actually
introduce in you know other areas where
it's
you know it's not so good so i think
there will be some lessons but they're
quite different populations the old
trafford population and partington
population are different in all sorts of
other ways
um so it's there are some there will
definitely be some lessons and we um
but there will be some other things that
are actually quite different
between the different populations i
think the main thing is it's it's that
one message doesn't work
for everyone um and it's making sure
that we have
a variety of messengers and i think
that's as important as anything making
sure that the people giving the message
have some credibility with the
population and the
the subgroups the population that you're
trying to deliver that message to
um and that's why you know we've been
really trying to make sure that we work
with different community groups and
and make sure that we get those messages
through delivered
by people who have some credibility and
know what they're talking about with the
population
um you know ideally are people who live
in the heart of those communities
um and again george if if you drill down
into a very small area that might
might be very low we've been in that you
know
larger larger sort of deprived area
yeah yeah yeah so i mean i'm sure george
and nigel will be able to talk more
about
you know that that it's it's really the
primacy of the
having that huge range of voices giving
the same messages
um and that same reassurance at the
moment is is
absolutely critical and i'm not giving
up
making sure that we just keep keep
making sure that offer remains
open to people um so that we can
vaccinate people at the point that
they're ready for vaccination
thank you thank you elena uh councillor
aquinola did you have a question at all
i did put my hand up and put it down
again but actually will come in because
um counselor haddad did um address some
of the issues but for me
there is a lot about messaging and
education but um practicalities as well
when it comes to statistics and i can
only talk about my own experience in
that i've got an over 80s father
who was one of it was no problem taking
up the vaccine
but what i can say is he doesn't access
all the information that trafford might
have been putting out
and because he lives although he lives
at limelight
he's been socially isolating since march
the only face he sees is the carers of
mine
and getting him his vaccination
wasn't an issue because luckily i drive
so i was able to take him to delamere
and my husband my husband and myself
were recently just getting over coverage
and the husband was quite ill actually
but not luckily not ill enough to have
to go into hospital touchwood
and he's recently well this week got his
letters for
vaccination and the options are not
limelight the option was
etienne which again for him as a car
driver is not an issue but for others in
the community it would be
and also it's that
the where are those messages about the
being volunteers to help people to get
to hospitals
and to the vaccinations because
like say my dad living in isolation in
his own little bubble
apart from the information he got from
me and the letter that came about his
vaccination didn't get any other
information
about support and he and
you know and i know there are other
people in the community for all kinds of
reasons why people don't want to take up
the vaccine
and i work in health and social care
then my other question was
because i've had a vaccine and my
vaccine was done
in buried because of work does that come
through to trafford
as me being on the figures for being
vaccinated or with that because these
because i'm thinking about the
workforces that are in traffic you might
work as carers elsewhere
and be vaccinated and i'm just i was
wondering about that as well
sorry they're waffling on a bit there so
that it goes back to so
the first thing is your vaccination goes
back to your gp
so wherever your gp is is where it's
then recorded
um we have some issues obviously some
people live in
trafford but have a gp outside trafford
and so on so
that's why we're making sure we look at
both our resident data which is the data
i guess in the council and our ccg data
which is on the registered population
which is the data martin will get in the
ccg
so that we do have two slightly
different data sets um
and that's why we were saying that we
were quite confident that the issues we
were seeing in re
in old trafford were real because martin
seeing hit them on his data set
and i'm seeing them on on my data set so
does that mean then because i was
vaccinated in bury
my doctor's under manchester do i come
under manchester's figures for
vaccination or do i come under traffords
you'll come under manchester's for the
ccg data but you'll cut you should it
should then be matched back to an
address and you should cut
we should guess the council should get
you as the
as through our data sets right because i
know there's a lot of people in old
trafford who are under manchester
doctors and i know it's always finished
that's that's right and that's that's
what so we've got it we've got it two
ways one
one one sorts it by postcode and sends
it to me
and one sorts it by gp and sends it to
martin
okay um the messaging sorry and the
messaging i think
i think the thing with with a lot of
health services is
that lots of people like you with your
dad even though he's isolated actually
you were there you took him to the
vaccination center you didn't need any
support
so what we often do is wait the first
tranche is
let everybody can sort themselves out
sort themselves out
and then we can see who are the people
who need additional support so it's
really about thinking you know we all
many many people will have done exactly
what you've done
and we don't necessarily you know
we could you know in terms of how we use
our resources
the people who can sort themselves out
we would rather leave to sort themselves
out
then we know who needs extra help and it
might be extra help because they need
support with transport and that can be
laid on
and tracy clark in the ccg and nigel and
his team
have been working on making sure that
we've got access to support where it's
needed
george and the voluntary sector groups
have been absolutely phenomenal with
this
then so once we know who are the people
who haven't had the vaccine we can then
start looking at
is it because they can't get to it in
which case how do we either get a
vaccine to them or how do we make sure
that
they're supported to get a vaccine to
get to the vaccine
or is it because they've got concerns
about the vaccination in which case we
can have the conversations about with
them
about those concerns but if you if you
think of we're trying to do this at
speed with 100
of the population in each of those age
groups if we can leave some people just
to sort themselves out
then we can just be focusing on the
people focusing our time and effort on
the people who might need some input
from us
rather than wasting our time and their
time bothering people who are actually
completely capable of get do
sorting it themselves and are really
committed to doing that so
it's it's if you like it say um it's a
it's how we use our resources and our
energy to best defect
so can i just ask then so if you haven't
had a response in say
a week or two are you then on the phone
to those people saying
what's the problem so this is what um
nigel and what we're working with now
with the um
with the voice of bme but also the gps
will also have been doing that
routinely they will have been put
looking at who's on their list who
hasn't attended
what might the reasons be what do they
need to be doing so they might be
sending out further reminders or they
might be saying
oh actually you know the practice nurse
could you give you know mrs blogs a ring
etc etc so um as i say that's one of the
benefits of the system going back into
the gp system because the gps know their
patients
and so they can really start thinking
about well i know why
x hasn't gone but x won't have gone
because they're just getting over
covered or
they've got some other condition so i'm
not going to ring them now
because i know that there's something
else going on in their life
i will ring them in a bit and i will you
know
so that so the gp you know there are
always some people
who for medical reasons can't have the
vaccination and also for other reasons
so
so the gps are in a good position to
start sorting through the
lists and start saying actually no you
know what i'm getting worried about the
fact that
you know mrs blogs hasn't had the
vaccination i don't know why they
haven't
i need you know the practice nurse needs
to ring her about x y anyway
i'll get the practice nurse to have a
conversation with her about the
vaccination at the same time
sorry martin martin
lost my virtual hand so i'm gonna have
to use my real one
sorry um just to reply to
uh council after noah's um question i i
think
in your household you've had the same
experience as i've had this weekend
which is my wife who's in cohort 8 got a
letter on saturday
inviting her to go to one of the local
mass vaccination centers
and she julie got on her mobile phone
and
you know julie booked herself an
appointment and one of the things that
we've talked about here
today is the way in which the the
national system has been constructed is
the mass vaccination centers are
different
from the way in which the gps are are
working
so what will happen there is with claire
my wife she's booked herself
in our gp will be unaware of the fact
that she's
booked herself in but when she's had a
vaccination that information will go
back to our gp and then they will be
aware that she had the first vaccination
and what our gp will be doing is they
will be contacting
people in that cohort but contacting
those people that their record shows
haven't already taken up that
opportunity for the vaccine and in the
first instance what they do is they send
out a text
and then when they don't get responses
from the people who've responded to the
text
then they get the practice admin staff
to phone up those patients who have not
responded
so um there are issues aren't there
about equity
in that because when my wife got a
letter
she's got a smartphone she's got a car
she's able to book that appointment
get herself in and therefore she's
probably going to get her appointment a
few days ahead of people
that don't have that i i think it's kind
of it's a it's a pragmatic
use of all the capacity isn't it that
we've got it's this thing about
getting out there as soon as possible
and and in all of this we are rightly
having conversations aren't we about
focusing on inequality focusing on those
people who are
least advantaged what we do need to
recognize isn't it is the overall speed
and pace of the vaccination program you
know as i said at the start of the
meeting if
we said in january we were already well
into cohort 8 by now
i would have been really really
surprised and really really pleased
so absolutely the focus of our
conversations and the focus of all the
questions and queries that are coming to
me through all the counselors in
trafford
are actually about inequality and about
making sure people don't get getting
left behind in that
so i just think recognizing that complex
system because we do have those
to use a management word of different
channels in which people are receiving
this
it is driving different things in this
the other thing i just wanted to say and
i'm sure ellen will back me up which is
um we're absolutely focused are we on
first else's second doses cohorts all of
those things
i would be amazed if we in the autumn
didn't have
a follow-up booster annual vaccination
program
for covid which may or may not be the
same as the flu vaccination program we
just don't know whether it's going to be
a single program with a single vaccine
or it's going to be two programs with
two vaccines
and everything we learn about all the
focus and effort from this
we need to keep hold of don't we and
make sure that when we get to the autumn
and we're doing this again
and next autumn and the autumn
afterwards that absolutely
you know we learn everything we do those
things at work and we don't spend time
and effort on the things that
don't work sorry chair it's a bit of a
long answer to that
so thank you thank you for that input i
i don't see any further questions and
i i know that we've covered um the uh
the i updated escalators from the
community engagement teams
again i thank nigel for it was a very
very thorough input
so come and move on to escalations and
update from the community enforcement
team and invite helen grant
thank you helen hello managed to get
myself off mute this week
i sat here like a goldfish i think a
couple of weeks ago
and yeah just a quick update um from us
so the um enforcement group still we
meets weekly and that's a really well
established group now which is partner
agencies
and departments within the council and
to make sure that areas of activity are
coordinated
and then more recently a kind of sub
operational group has been established
from that which is environmental health
licensing greater manchester police and
and ourselves in community
safety so that's looking at specific
premises specific businesses specific
areas of concern where we might be doing
joint
operations on those and we are still
getting
um reports of breaches and still
residential
breaches not to the same level as before
and some of those do
contain an element of antisocial
behavior which may have been reported
anyway um and they are kind of less than
we were
um but we're still getting things like
you know reports of birthday parties
reports of people having groups of
friends around
a weekend and and i think you know it's
possibly harder in terms of the
communications because everyone's now
looking at these dates
as we're coming out of lockdown and they
want to be there sooner than we are and
reiterate your point chair that this
isn't a kind of sprint out of lockdown
down into me it's kind of like walking
on ice where you take a step forward and
then then see how we are
so i think it's more effective for us to
kind of communicate
with our residents we need kind of
businesses in everyone in trafford to be
doing this together
um there's a big focus in terms of
making our plans now for those key dates
as we start to ease those restrictions
i think probably lots of the country
kind of watched waiting to find out when
licensed premises would be back open
and that's obviously the weekend after
easter
so we've started having kind of
conversations with partner agencies to
make sure that
you know the the response to that is is
fair and joined up
and we've got an action plan template
that we'll be completing
and we'll bring back to this meeting
with more detail
um but obviously there's kind of key
things around that the first
um stage of the opening of licensed
premises obviously outdoor
and central government kind of obviously
want local government to be supporting
our businesses and licensed premises and
receiving more applications for
tables and chairs and things to be
outside on the pavement obviously as the
council we've got to balance
that with the need for people to get
past who might be
in wheelchairs or you know with children
in in buggies and
and so on and so forth and and
potentially
you know kind of dependent on whether
maybe it could be a bit like the mad
friday before christmas
so making plans in terms of resourcing
and
you know probably the first kind of
night out that people may have had in a
long time
and there's obviously a risk there of
kind of alcohol related disorder as well
and so
making plans around that and in terms of
resourcing
so there's lots and lots kind of going
on around it
we do kind of kind of stress to the
public and to our
kind of businesses um you know work with
us on this we've got these kind of dates
let's not blow it now and it's really
really positive
about the vaccinations but not everybody
is vaccinated yet
and so we're getting there so let's just
kind of work together and come out of
this safely
um but yeah thank you very much for
everyone's support
thank you helen and uh clearly um
when we talk about uh the reopening of
good luck for example licensed premises
it's the earliest date is the 12th of
april
but of course what we're seeing now is
that a lot of our premises and retail
have latched on to this state they're
advertising now that they're going to
open
and yet nothing is set in stone and
clearly it could be a busy time for you
if the government find that they can't
allow
it to reopen on the 12th um and
it's going to be a big problem and it
will be resource intensive for you so
thank you for the work that you are
continuing to do and the team
uh in what are challenging circumstances
are there any questions at all for for
helen
i don't see any um item six is about
activity and feedback but what i want to
raise here is something i discussed with
eleanor and ellen
you wrote to me this week about the need
for um mass testing volunteers if we
have coveted outbreaks
on variants and wondering what the we
can do as a body to support or find
these volunteers if we need to do so
would you like to
speak to that yes so this is if we get a
new variant
of concern so they had this is what they
had in manchester with operational eagle
we might get asked to do mass testing um
or offer mass testing to
a large number of people which and that
tends to then involve
people going door to door um asking you
know
telling people about the opportunity for
testing and it also gives a great
opportunity for
um further conversations about other
things unrelated to
testing um but wider coveted issues to
to be discussed so um we're really
hoping that we don't
end up having to do um a mass testing
program
um it would be much better if we could
manage not to have any variance of
concern in the borough
but if we do we might have to mobilize
at speed
i know that we're starting conversations
with um through the community engagement
team
um and also with george and others so
it's i think we probably
it's just really to flag here that we
might need to have
some volunteers who can get out of very
quick notice
and it's really thinking about what
would the what would our voluntary where
and i'm absolutely convinced that the
people of trafford will come up
and support this i know we will get
those volunteers
but it's really thinking how do we make
sure that we've got everything ready
that um the voluntary sector and others
who will be the people who will be
absolutely critical to us in recruiting
and supporting the volunteers
what do they need from us now what do
you need from us now
to make you confident if you were to
recruit volunteers
in in making sure that they knew what
they had to do when they had to do it
etc
so how much how can we make sure that
we've got some really good planning in
place we've got some names and
indicative ideas
of who people would approach and what
you need from us to make sure that that
that volunteer offer that our volunteers
feel really well supported and our
voluntary sector organizations
feel really well supported in um in some
in engaging and supporting the
volunteers through this process
so it's a request to the groups to think
about
um who would who would you approach and
what do you need from us
to make that approach really feel good
thanks george yeah um i think one of the
things
that we should be really clear about is
that we've we've got
some systems in place that work so we've
got trafford partnership we've got
thrive trafford and we've got the new
community engagement team
we've got the community hubs and we've
got trafford collective and i think
one of the things that we're doing at
the minute is trying to collate as much
of that as possible
to make it as straightforward as
possible i think
the best example is the work that we've
done through
recruiting and supporting volunteers to
support people at the vaccination
centers because that was all done
really quickly we set up a vaccine a
vaccination
volunteer group so we have been able to
respond quickly and i suppose from my
point of view
what i would be asking for everybody is
to think about what have we got how do
we consolidate it
and how do we make it really
straightforward for trafford residents
because we know that for are willing and
happy to be volunteers what we need to
be able to do is to be ready to say
this is the support that you get this is
what we'd like you to do and this is
where we'd like you to go
so i think we can start working on that
pretty much
you know as soon as we need to and we'll
link in with eleanor her team
and the the public engagement team to
make sure we get that right
thank you george thanks for that um
moving on i have to have an only the
business item
and i'm going to invite helen collins
and kate murdock to talk to us about
contact tracing and outbreak management
and as a chair of governors at the
school that's had an outbreak management
meeting
i'll be very interested to hear helen uh
about that
thank you so it's just a quick update
really because um
we just wanted to make you aware that
we're still uh working very hard on
the contact tracing and outbreak
management side of things so
in terms of the contact racing
um we deal with the level two so these
are the individuals who haven't been
able to be contacted by the national
team
they're still coming through and trisha
and max
and a variety of our contact tracers who
work in
access trafford the libraries and the
cctv team
are still working really hard and i
would just say
when they do make contact with the
individuals they talk very much
about um welfare need as well so we do
link it all together
so um and that's that has been a little
bit more quieter than we
have had previously but since it started
in september we've dealt with over a
thousand cases for the level two so
that's really good
in terms of outbreaks i just wanted to
give you a quick update really
um we are just dealing with one school
at the moment with an
um uh outbreak ongoing we've had very
few positives come through from the
secondary school children testing which
i think kate was ready for her phone to
melt with phone calls but we've had i
think about two or three
have come through the lft testing but
obviously we would expect when they go
to second round of testing to pick
up a few additional ones as well um it's
the business messaging and the
businesses that are keeping us busy at
the moment so
we're working with seven large
businesses across trafford at the moment
that have outbreaks
um ongoing so we we taught them through
a number of different
uh issues obviously identifying their
particular
issues and reasons why spread has
occurred but also very much
encouraging them around the lfd testing
of staff
and also i think which is crucial at the
moment is
um enabling staff to continue to work
from home now that schools have gone
back
i think they were the key messages that
we just wanted to share with you to make
you aware that we are
um we're continuing to be busy and we
have anticipated
an increase um over the next couple of
weeks just because of the increase in
mixing nothing
nothing significant but that's what
we're looking at at the moment
kate was there anything else i think
just to add also that we're developing
our work on enhanced contact tracing and
being a little bit more proactive with
businesses
and because we've got access to more
data now so we can identify
businesses when two or more cases have
occurred within a two-week period
so we're proactively contacting those
businesses
giving them lots of support and
preventative
measures to hopefully avoid any any
larger outbreak situations
thank you thank you uh helen and kate
and and you'll be a stunning agenda item
from now on so we look forward to
further
update of further region council dad did
you have a question at all
sorry it was when uh eleanor was talking
about mass
mass voluntary um testing
capacity and which is an excellent idea
obviously to be
ready have a ready to go
group of people i just wondered is that
something that could also be
rolled out to support our schools
because
you know i'm school governor and i know
that um you know
it's a massive undertaking you've got
two you know i think we've got
2 000 children in our school and to do
that kind of
you know lateral flow testing is is
on it's twice a week isn't it is really
is really difficult is there any
capacity there to help the schools thank
you
[Music]
shall i answer this one eleanor so we've
worked very closely with schools
councillor haddan
and um they only need to test in school
three times on return
so that it's really this week and next
week which are going to be the busiest
weeks to schools
um i have to say i think the schools
have been absolutely phenomenal
they've dealt with it amazingly they've
caught they've trained up
staff they've got pta in they've got
parent other parent volunteers
we've worked with three schools really
to to offer them support
but in the end actually they they
managed to
to um set up their testing system
themselves which is brilliant
after the third test they go to home
testing so the children will be testing
themselves
at home twice a week um they need
schools need to have a very small
testing site on
a testing station on site and that's for
children who may choose not to test at
home
for whatever reason so it'd only be for
the majority schools i imagine it would
only be one
booth and at the moment test to release
which is when you
test children who are contacts of a case
um
isn't live so we're not doing that it's
literally just testing twice
well three times on return to school and
then twice at home so at the moment the
capacity
isn't required but we have you know had
those discussions with schools
thank you does that answer your question
the cancer dad
thank you thank you very much all right
and council accordingly
uh you've just got your hand up thank
you
comes accordingly is that a legacy hand
sorry managed to knock the whole thing
over this time
sent me up app device flying across the
room i just had to
retrieve it to what boots it um
it's going back to the liaison with
employers obviously
some employers are more keen than others
we had the issue with dhl which was very
regrettable um
where they didn't really support their
workers at all
and um they had an outbreak
in trafford park because of it and
clearly the union at cwu has been very
concerned about that
i suppose that
whilst dhl may have been dealt with um
there are still pockets of employ there
is so much of um
the sort of gig economy going on in
traffic park and what have you that it
becomes quite
difficult um and it's really what can we
do with those employers that are not
playing ball
helena would you like to answer so
um we're doing our best what we're
trying to do is work with the
businesses overall and just make sure
that everybody understands the rules
um because i think one of the things
we've been surprised about and helen and
kate i'm sure will come in on this is
that there are some businesses
who you know even though we've been
working in
with covert for a year living with coke
for a year some businesses
um don't seem to have put all the
measures in place that they should have
done
so ellie has been doing some fantastic
stuff on the comms kate and
helen have been working with all of the
outbreaks and we are
recruiting to our program management
team and one of the posts that we're
recruiting to will be leading on that
business engagement
we've been tying in with stephen james
and his team on trying to make sure that
we get those messages out to businesses
i think what we've found is more
recently is because the new variant is
more
well now the dominant variant is more
infectious businesses that have been
managing
okay earlier on in you know
this this time last year for example or
through the summer
they've suddenly started seeing a really
big increase in in outbreaks
over the last couple of months because
of the new variant being more infectious
so it's that message now about this
variant needs us to be doing
everything scrupulously um we absolutely
cannot take our eye off the ball as
people were saying people are very
very set on the dates in the roadmap
those roadmap dates are
if you like are not and not before not a
not a guarantee
and so it's really we're really trying
to reinforce the messages with the
businesses
um but it it is very difficult when
we've got a lot of very small businesses
that perhaps aren't on
you know don't that aren't on our
business engagement lists and so on
um but we're really trying to make sure
that we get out to those businesses and
also to
not only to the businesses as employers
but also making sure that the general
public is aware enough of what
what they should and shouldn't be doing
so i don't know whether
ellie wants to say something on on the
work we've been doing around the comms
on that
or helen or laura on the work we're
picking up helen collins on the work
we're picking up with the
with um businesses the other group have
been absolutely phenomenal on this and
i'm not sure on the call
is our environmental health team who
have been working
absolutely tirelessly throughout making
sure that they get that guidance out to
businesses
they do the visits and they and they
give the information and the guidance to
businesses
so they have been absolutely amazing all
the way through this
um and it's but we do have real capacity
issues
with that so it's really making sure
that we can try and
through the additional program support
we're putting in that we can get that
reach
just echo eleanor said the regulatory
team have been phenomenal and they are
brilliant
um we are meeting this afternoon to uh
pull together kind of a strategic
group for businesses around covert so
that we can
kind of increase the preventative
element of the work that we're doing
but also to support ellie in the raft of
different communications as well
so work is ongoing at the moment
thank you helen um i'm conscious of the
time
uh is there any other business uh
i don't haven't gotten they don't see
anyone raised in the hand can i kind of
close by saying that i will be attending
uh an lga webinar tomorrow on uh
combating vaccine hesitancy
so there's anything from that i will
feed it back to you eleanor
and kind of close by really thanking
everyone for their attendance but more
importantly thanking our public health
teams
our environmental health teams our
regulatory service teams
for the sterling work that you are doing
uh in
in combating kobe 19 in trafford and and
i really do want to
you know please pass on my thanks to
them all
and and um let's see but hopefully we
can see some light at the end of the
tunnel but now is not the time
to be complacent the next meeting is on
the 24th of march that'll be our last
meeting before the council and has
purger
and we'll be making a decision about
future meetings during the purdue
period thank you very much and everyone
have a have a lovely day
thank you thanks bye now bye-bye